هولندا اول واصلين الى ربع نهائي كاس
العالم 2022 بعد الفوز على امريكا بثلاثيه
مقابل هدف وحيد بكل صراحه مباراه
المنتخب الهولندي من البدايه وحتى النهايه
رغم انه كان في بعض الدقائق الهولندا خافت
فيها امريكا سجلت الهدف وكان في قلق من
تسجيل هدف ثاني ولكن هدف دومبريس قتل كل
شيء اللي صار بكل امانه ونحكي قصه
المباراه من البدايه امريكا بدات مباراه
بشكل ممتاز جدا كانت اخطر على المرمى
الهولندي كادت ان تسجل عن طريق بولست دوله
تدخل نوفبرت اللي خلص الكره وخلص انقراض
صريح للمنتخب الامريكي بعد ذلك سيطره
امريكا كان اقرب للتسجيل حتى الدقيقه
التاسعه هدف بعكس مجريات اللاعب تماما
يسجل هدف الاول لمنتخب هولندا عند الدقيقه
التاسعه مثل المحاكينا
وهذا الهدف بكل صراحه بيلخص الفكره
الهجوميه الوحيده اللي اعتمد عليها
المنتخب الهولندي بشوت المباراه الاول وهي
خروج سريع بالكره عبر تمريرات سريعه جدا
تصل الى دومبريس على الجهه اليمنى دوم
فريز بيلعب بالعرضيه للقاده من الخلف في
هذه المره كان منفسدي باي سجل الهدف الاول
لمنتخب هولندا هولندا بعد ذلك تركت
الاستحواذ للمنتخب الامريكي ولعبت على
المرتد وحاولت ان تضرب امريكا بالكرات او
بالهاجمات المرتده بعد قطع الكره في منتصف
الملعب واللي كان يصير عاده اوقات كثيره
بجانب المنتخب الامريكي لانه بصراحه
لاعبين وسط الامريكان ما كانوا مميزين جدا
بعمليه الخروج
ضع ذلك نجح المنتخب الهولندي بالفعل
بتسجيل هدف الثاني في المباراه عن طريق
بيلبلين توقيت الهدف كان قاتل بالنسبه
للمنتخب الامريكي بكل صراحه لما تلقى هدف
في دقيقه 46 بتكون امور صعبه جدا عليك انك
ترجع بالمباراه الهدف الثاني كان نسخه طبق
الاصل على الهدف الاول تمريره من نصف
الملعب
العرضيه هذه المره كانت بلند اللي جاي من
وراء وسجل الهدف لا ينتهي الشوط الاول
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء لصالح المنتخب
الاول لاحظ انه وسط هولندا مش كتير عنده
اخطاء عنده مشاكل عنده نقص بالضغط مش قادر
يضغط بشكل مطلوب على لاعبين المنتخب
الامريكي وكان في خطوره باكثر من مره من
جانب الامريكان وكانوا قريبين من التسجيل
بسبب وسط هولندا الضعيف في التعامل مع
الهجمات الامريكيه وفي الضغط
لكن بن خالد دارك الامور على السريع واجر
تبديلين سريعين جدا بخروج بيرون وخروج
كلاسن والهند الاثنين لاعبين وسط كلاسين
كان هو لاعب وسط الهجومي وادي رون هو
البفت الثاني او لاعب الارتكاز الثاني الى
جانب ديون»
وهو لاعب رقم 20 دخل وشغل مكان ديرون وصار
هو لاعب الوسط الثاني الى جانبه هاي
تبديلات عملت حاله من العمق بنص ملعب
منتخب هولندا وصار وسط ملعب منتخب هولندا
اكثر عمقا واكثر الى حد ما ولكن جاء هدف
المنتخب الامريكي بلحظات من عدم التركيز
من جانب الدفاع هولندا قبل الهدف كان في
تمريره خاطئه راح فيها مهاجم امريكا
انفراد وسدد الكره ولكن كان مدافع منتخب
هولندا بيشيل الكره عن خط المرمى ويحمي
المنتخب هولندا من الهدف بعد ذلك الهدف
الامريكي طبعا
بخطا ايضا خطا بالخروج بالكره من جانب
المنتخب الهولندي سجل هدف الاول وهو انبلش
الشك يفوت لنفوسه عقليه لاعبيه هولندا
وصار يحسه بالخطر انه امريكا ممكن ترجع
امريكا صارت اخطر ولكن الذكاء الاوروبي
المعتاد ان هولندا استاد الامريكان
ليطلعوا المناطقهم لا يهاجمه اكثر لانه
المنتخب الامريكي لما سجل الهدف الاول طمع
وصار بدو يسجل هدف التعادل وهذا امر طبيعي
ومشروع وبالتالي لاعبوا امريكا للهجوم
وبهاي اللحظه كان المنتخب الهولندي
لا يرفع ديلان كره على الجهه اليمنى
هالمره دون فريس ما كان دوره انه يصنع
اللاعب لا كان دورا انه يسجل ونجح في
تسجيل الهدف الثالث للمنتخب هولندا وقت
المباراه وانتهى كل شيء بعد ذلك الامور
بعد الهدف هذا خلاص انتهت بالنسبه لمنتخب
امريكا اقتنع عن النصارى خارج البطوله
وهولندا اقتنعت للدور ربع النهائي الان
هولندا راح تنتظر الفائز من مباراه
الارجنتين واستراليا اللي راح تلعب بعد
شويه وبالتالي حتى نشوف اول مباراه ربع
نهائي في هذه البطوله هولندا مثل ما حكينا
اول متاهلين الى ربع النهائي يعني ممكن
نقول باقل مجهود ممكن بصراحه لحتى تواجه
على الاغلب المنتخب الارجنتيني ولكن في
هذه البطوله لا تامن الفرق الصغرى لانه
استراليا قد تصنع الفارق وقد تتاهل الى
ربع النهائي لتواجه هولندا خلينا نشوف شو
راح يصير مبروك لعشاق للمنتخب الهولندي
وهاردلك لجماهير المنتخب الامريكي